Captain Marvel is the introduction of
the most powerful hero in the MCU to
date it involves a complex web of
characters new and old and it's also a
semi prequel set in the 90s which means
there are a lot of questions left
largely unexplored be warned major
spoilers ahead
Captain Marvel gives us yet another
wrinkle in the history of the tesseract
the first Infinity stone to make its way
to earth we knew that the tesseract aka
the space stone was found by Hydra in
the 1940s recovered by shield after
Captain America's disappearance and then
stolen by Loki in the 2010 now we know
that dr. Wendy Lawson aka Marvel was a
gifted Kree scientist who used the
tesseract as part of her work on project
Pegasus using it to power a Lightspeed
engine before her death sometime around
the late 80s in the six years between
Marvel's death and the rise of Carol
Danvers as a superhero
the tesseract apparently just sat hidden
in her cloaked orbiting lab which raises
a few questions
she was presumably allowed the use of it
by shield so why didn't she looking for
it when she died how could something so
important go missing for so long
one of the standout stars of Captain
Marvel is goose marvel's quote/unquote
cat by the end of the film it's revealed
that goose is a fleur c'n an alien
species that looks like an earth feline
on the outside but also packs deadly
tentacles and the ability to consume
objects several times its size during
the film's climactic moments goose
devour several Kree warriors intimidates
other aliens and even eats the tesseract
so fury won't have to touch it because
we know what happens when the wrong
people touch Infinity stones
then in the post-credits scene we see
goose quark the infinity stone up onto
Fury's desk and back into shield custody
is goose still hanging around the MCU
somewhere we may never know but goose
and fury seem like good pals
the legendary Nick Fury still has both
of his eyes for most of Captain Marvel
and he's still rather green is a lowly
level 3 SHIELD agent
we know that clearance levels within
shield go up to 10 with a couple of even
more secretive levels above that which
is where fury eventually ends up the
film ends around 1995 which gives him a
little more than a decade to become
director by the time he meets Tony Stark
in 2008 we know he gets the director job
at performing a relationship with
Alexander Pierce who leaves the position
to become Secretary of the world
security council what we don't know is
exactly how long that took Fury's rapid
rise through the ranks from a Wimpy
level 3 agent had to be meteoric right
that's a yes or no question yes among
the film's many familiar faces is Ronan
the accuser Prix dispatcher of Justice
and the main villain in guardians of the
galaxy there Ronan is a rogue accuser
who becomes a terrorist fanatic afters
people sign a peace treaty with Xander
but 20 years earlier he's still obedient
to the Kree government working in close
collaboration with yon raagh and the
rest of the star force
we know that Ronan eventually goes rogue
devises people and ultimately dies in a
struggle over the Power Stone which is
not an uncommon theme for Infinity
stones
at the end of Captain Marvel though he
says that he'll one day return for Carol
a human weapon so does he ever return
for her she leaves earth at the end of
the film but did he and the other
accusers ever try to seek her out in
space we don't know right now but a
rivalry between Captain Marvel and a
Kree accuser could be interesting
another familiar face is core at the
pursuer who by the end of his life he's
one of Ronan's top lieutenants but his
eventual defection to follow Ronan is
hinted at only briefly in a scene in
which he seems more willing than Yan Rob
to tell the accuser about Carroll's
whereabouts the last time we see Korath
in the film he's battling Carol only to
be defeated along with the rest of the
star force
Korath stayed at the end of Captain
Marvel isn't exactly clear but we know
that when he returns in guardians of the
galaxy he's working with Ronan and has
several enhancements including equipment
grafted into his head so what happened
did Ronan rebuild Korath and give him
his enhancements what turns one Kree
against another probably Thanos it's
always Thanos one of the most exciting
pieces to a potential story in Captain
Marvel is the Rambo's Carole's best
friend Maria and her daughter Monica who
idolizes auntie Carol when she's a pilot
even more so and it becomes clear that
she's a superhero in Marvel's comics we
know that Monica Rambeau actually held
the Captain Marvel title in 1982 long
before carol did she since shifted
superhero identity several times and is
currently known as spectrum by any name
she's a vital hero in the Marvel
Universe who once led the Avengers and
can summon tremendous power of her own
she'd be in her 30s by the time the
present-day MCU events happen so will we
see her show up as a hero scrolls are an
insidious force that will infiltrate any
planet using their shape-shifting
abilities and ultimately take it over
the supreme intelligence tells us this
yawn raagh tells us this and even carol
tells us this except that it's a big fat
lie the remaining scrolls in the
galaxies are actually refugees running
from the Kree as they look for a new
home something Marvel was hoping to
solve with her Lightspeed engine with
Carol's help they eventually head off
into
the stars to find a new planet to settle
on and that's the last we fear of them
do the scrolls find a planet to call
home if they do then they've had more
than two decades to colonize and rebuild
since the events of Captain Marvel so
will they eventually become an expanding
power in the galaxy again the resilience
of the scrolls and their ability to rise
up and conquer again and again even
after their defeat is one of their comic
book trademarks sometimes they're
humanity's enemy and sometimes they're
an ally so where are the scrolls now and
whose side are they on and will they be
the ones that come back and help kick
some vanos but when Carol finally
remembers how she got her powers and
ultimately arrived at the Kree homeworld
everything she knows is flipped upside
down instead of being an ally young raga
and his pals are the ones who shot down
Danvers and marvels Lightspeed ship and
killed Marvell when Carol destroys the
engine and absorbs its powers young
rogue abducts her and hides her memories
from her for six years after Carol finds
out she defeats her former mentor and
sends him back to Halle where he'll have
to face retribution so what happens the
young rod is it a light reprimand prison
death pipe lurkin will we ever see him
again in a universe this complex anyone
left alive is potentially fodder for
sequels Carol Danvers receives her
powers when she destroys Marvel's
Lightspeed engine granting her
superhuman strength speed resilience and
the photon blasts that become her
defining power but that explosive engine
was powered by the tesseract aka the
space stone an object of tremendous
power that's played numerous major roles
in the Marvel Universe the space stone
can transport its bearer across great
distances as it did with the Red Skull
and the First Avenger and Thanos an
infinity war we also know that it can
possibly be triggered from afar as Loki
did in the Avengers Carol Danvers gets
her power from it just as Vision derived
some of his abilities from the mine
stone embedded in his head does this
mean she can manipulate the space stone
or use some fraction of its abilities is
she as intimately connected to it as
vision is to the mind stone then she
teleports these are all enormous
questions man Avengers endgame might
ultimately provide us with some answers
we all know you have to be
careful with those stones though check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about
Marvel movies are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]